[موسيقى]
بالحديث عن الاصلاحات الحقيقيه التي
يريدها المواطن التونسي ما هي اولويات
البرلمان الحالي
بالنسبه لينا يعني هناك يعني بالنسبه
للوضع في تونس هناك تراكمات حدثت يعني ما
قبل
وخاصه في العشريه الاخيره
يعني شهدت البلاد يعني عده ازمات وعدت
تقلبات سئيمها الشعب التونسي وبالتالي
فما ينتظره الشعب التونسي هو استقرار
الحياه السياسيه
نمو المسار الاقتصادي واستقرار الحياه
الاجتماعيه وبالتالي
فان على الوظيفه التنفيذيه وكذلك البرلمان
الاهتمام بكل ما من شانه ان يصلح
عديد من القطاعات مثل يعني
تعليم مثل الساحه العموميه مثل النقل مثل
القضاء يعني على البيروقراطيه الاداريه
مثل يعني الاهتمام بالنواحي الاقتصاديه بث
الطمانينه لدى افراد الشعب التونسي وانه
بخلاصه القول انه في الماضي
استشرت يعني ثقافه الياس في البلاد واليوم
على البرلمان الحالي وكذلك الوظيفه
التنفيذيه العمل على استبدال ثقافه الياس
بثقافه الامل لا اكثر ولا اقل يعني كل
واحده مما ذكرت سعادتك بحاجه الى وقت طويل
من اجل تحقيقها على الاقل نبدا بالخطوه
الاولى لكن كما تقولون في تونس عدم
التنصيص على مفهوم المعارضه داخل البرلمان
في النظام الداخلي للبرلمان في الحقيقه
يبدو امر غير مالوف
هل هذا يعني ان هناك موالاه فقط في هذا
البرلمان ولا في معارضه
لا لا
بالذات نعرف طبيعه يعني الانتخابات التي
تمت ويعني
وقع بمجيبها انتخاب نواب البرلمان لاول
مره في تونس تطبق يعني
الانتخابات على اساس دوائر فرديه بنظام
الدورتين واغلب النواب هم نواب مستقلون
على الاحزاب يعني ما عدا حزبين شارك في
الانتخابات لكن لو نظرنا الى عدد النواب
لا وجدنا ان النواب المستقلين
يمثلون الاغلبيه
يعني الواضحه والاغلبيه المطلقه وبالتالي
في البرلمانات السابقه كانت هناك احزاب
تترشح هناك احزاب يعني حزب او مجموعه من
الاحزاب يفوزون بالاغلبيه ومن لا يفوز
بالاغلبيه يعني ينتقل للمعارضه بحيث ان
الحزب الذي يفوز بالاغلبيه يكون الحكومه
والحزب الذي لم يفوز بالاغلبيه ينتمي
المعارضه الان يعني الناب هو مستقل
وبالتالي هو اصبح اكثر استقلاليه من
نظم البرلمانيه سابقه بالنسبه لهذه العهده
النيابيه بدليل وانه النائب حر في التصويت
على القوانين اما مع قوانين او ضد قوانين
ومع ذلك
لا يعتبر من
المعارضه اذا ما سوت ضد قانون ولا يعتبر
من الموالاه اذا سوت مع قانون